hello YouTube Chancellor slim offense
this is Virginia and today we are going
to discuss about a trap and the Dutch
defense now the trap Springs out from
the opening known as a Staunton gambit
now the more orders can be like this
so why place b4 and the general response
of the back will be fi and here we will
play E for which is known as a Staunton
gambit now the first thing you should
notice is it's very hard for black not
to accept the pawn so for example if
black will continue with the usual lines
of the Dutch defense for example Knight
to f6 then it will be a very great game
for white so for example white can go
for Aoife and here if black foolishly
play Knight to e4 then this night will
be a goner so that's not possible
so the general place where the night
goes is Knight goes to d5 we're here we
can attack the knight again after Knight
goes to b6
we can play Bishop to g5 you can see why
it has a so much space in the center and
there's also one cheap trap available
here for example if it's specially
playing a very quick games or the bullet
games if you open and play foolishly at
6 then you can checkmate him but this
modest so that's why not accepting the
pawn can be very dangerous for black and
that's why here black has to accept the
pawn sacrifice which is of course efore
and here the stuntin gambit theory
continues with the Knight to c3 now you
can see the knight is attacking the pawn
and if the black responded with the D
file then it will transpose to our main
variation so the general response of the
black will be here Knight to f6
developing a piece and also defending
the pawn and now here black plays B G
file now if person know about the
stuntin gambit then he will probably
play Knight to c6 or c6 moves well in
those cases what I'm strongly
recommending you is you play f3 move and
learn the theory section of the stuntin
gambit and that is a very aggressive way
to play against the strontium Gumby if
you do not want to gambit your pawn I
recommend you can simply capture the
knight and regain the pole and you can
look forward for a strong middle game
but that's not the case all the time
many players especially people under 18
hundred plus and sometimes people in the
two thousand plus if they started to
learn started to play the - defense and
they do not know about the strontium
gambit then they will likely to play
this blunder which is
defy and the first glance it looks very
obvious that it's not only protecting
the pawn but black has a very good
center-right but this is of London mu
and here our chest raft exists so I give
you a few seconds can you find a winning
continuation here for the white okay
the winning continuation I hope you find
it it's very easy so first you capture
the night and here there are few
possibility for the black if black
capture this pawn by the gee-pole then
we'll simply give a check and after King
goes to the only square which is three
seven we can simply capture the pawn and
after King goes to p8 then again we'll
give a check and after King again goes
to d7 you can castle on the Queen side
and you can see not only blacks epon
will fall and that will make white a
pawn up but black King position is very
very shaky so it's a almost winning
position for the white
now
after this capture the most general
response will be across f6
and after this we get a wearing position
by a simple queen check and here the
most logical reply will be the g6 but
here will capture the pawn and now you
can see not only we have regained the
pawn but now we are threatening to
capture one loop one so black response
is very much forceful li has to accept
the Queen and after Knight takes Queen
you can see it's a lost position for the
black and I can't tell you so many
people have just blindly go for this and
I have won many quick games like this so
here black cannot defend the to point C
seven left six and the most important
thing is black has to defend C cell
phone otherwise it will lose the rook in
the corner so the most obvious response
of the black will be king to d8 but
after we we capture the f6 again the e4
pawn is pressurized and one of my own
game where my opponent play a very good
moves but still at then he lost let me
show you that game so in one of my game
my opponent plays Bishop f5 defending
the pawn I played Knight to e2 so my
simple plan inside goes to g3 and
recapturing the pole
and here he played knight c6 now right
now I don't have to worry about night
capturing that one because my rook can
come to the D fall and that will pin the
night so I goes on with the knight g3
here he plays Bishop g7 and after I
capture the pawn then he played rook to
e8 now it looks like black is winning a
piece but no it's not because now white
can simply defend with the f3 and the
bad thing is black does not have any
pawns to attack the knight and hear my
opponent takes the pawn I cancel on the
Queen side and here he unpin his eye
with King to e7
but after c3 Knight to c6 and Knight
takes F Phi G cross F Phi Knight to c5
rook to d8 and Bishop to b5 my opponent
play a6 and after Bishop captures he
captures it's time for the assessment
and you can see black pawns are all over
the place and it's simply a very very
bad position for the black the simple
reason is black king is very much
exposed you can see these phones they
all are scattered and look at the good
structure of the white pawns so please
look forward for this trap and I give
you guarantee many people will fall into
this trap especially if you do not have
any system against Dutch defense I
strongly recommend you you look forward
for this trap well I hope you enjoy my
video feel free to comment and I'll meet
you soon bye